>> ALL MAKE THE PROMISE CALL
PAU MORE LAWYER
>> WELCOME BACK TO LAS VEGAS.
NOW IT'S ALMOST TACO TUESDAY.
AND IT'S ALSO GET IN HERE IF
YOU TALK DOES KNOWS HOW TO
CELEBRATE RIGHT TO SHOW US
WHAT'S ON THE MENU, THIS
SMELLS INCREDIBLE, YOU KNOW
MEDIA HAVE BECOME A TREND, I
KNOW YOU GUYS ALL SEE IT WITH
THE CHEESE WHATNOT WE'LL GOING
UP MAKES AGAIN IT'S SYMBOLIC
TO READINGS.
>> HE SAID YEAH DIES BECAUSE
WHEN WE HAD TO THROW A PARTY
FOR A FEW 100 PEOPLE AND
YOU'RE POLL. YOU KNOW WE HAD A
FEW A LOT OF PEOPLE SO WE
DIDN'T HAVE A PER PERSON
O JAVIER HAES ALE $50 A PERSON
WOULD LIKE WE COULD AFFORD
THAT GOING SO
BROUGHT ALONG
HAD OWE HAD A FEW WHAT TO 300
PEOPLE SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT
IS MORE OF OUR TRADITION NOW
IT'S A TREND THAT IS GOING A
LITTLE WRONG BECAUSE IT'S
ABOUT THE ACTUAL ME OKAY NOW
PEOPLE WANT YOU TO DIP IN AND
THEY WANT YOU TO CHEESE AND IT
JUST AS SALTINESS AND WHY IS
OUR IT'S BETTER THAN EVERYONE
ELSE IS BECAUSE WE HAVE
CHILDREN THE CAGE. YES, NO ONE
HAS CHINA. BUT LET'S SAY YOU
ARE DOING SOMETHING RIGHT AND
I CAN'T WAIT ANY LONGER I WANT
YOU TO MAKE HIT A SOMETHING
THAT SOME PEOPLE USE GO
BECAUSE OF THE GAME AND THAT'S
WHAT WE DID A GOOD GOING GOUP.
>> BUT NOW WE'RE ABLE TO DO IT
WITH BEEF BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE GOAT AND YOU KNOW
THERE'S A CERTA AIN A GAMEA  A
THAT THCOMETHS WITHTH THSO WTHEH
THE BONEE S E E AND THAT'S WHER
GAME IS COMING FROM SO YES, I
LIKE THAT OKAY WE'RE TOPPING
IT OFF WITH SOME ONIONS. AND
SOME SLUGS SHOW A LITTLE LINE
TO CUT THROUGH H THE FACT THA
AS   YOU'RE PREPARING THIS WE'
TALKING ABOUT A MINUTE AGO,
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING NEW THAT
YOU'VE ADDED TO THE MENU
YOU'RE HOLDING OFF AGOFAIOFOFOF
OFBECAOFUSE IT WAS JUST A TREND
RIGHT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
GROW 18 TO ME THAT WE'RE DOING
IT. WELL AND THIS IS KIND OF A
SECRET MENU ITEM THAT ISAT NOATT
ATGOINATG TOAT ANYATWHERE YOU O
KNOW AN HOUR TELLING ALL OF
OUR WATCHING IT. I SAY YOU
WANT TO TO THE 40 FRESHEN
FOOD. SECRET WORD THEN TAKE A
BITE OF IT THAT YOU GUYS AGURE
ALSO KNOWN FOR YOUR MARGARITA
YOUR COCKTAILS WHAT DID YOU OU
BRING WITH US HAVE OUR TO DO
OUR FAMOUS WHEN OUR HOUSE, THE
BLOOD ORANGE. WE HAVE
WATERMELON AND WE JUST
INTRODUCED QUITE WHILE BUT
WITH YOU GUYS AND WE E E E MAEE
CE.
>> SMALLS. LLBUT LIKE I SAID,
THAT'S THE MOST ARE THE KIND
SLOPPY AT THE SAME HOW DARE
YOU I LOVE IT, AND YOU HAVE
LOOK AT IT INSIDE THE
LOCATIONS HERE WE HAVE
DOWNTOWN AND GRANDMA SEE
PEOPLE TAKING OVER THE CITY
WON'T TALK ABOUT IT. I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT IT I LIKE THAT'S A
LOOK AT I'M GOING TO HELP
MYSELF TO THIS BECAUSE IT
SOUNDS AMAZING MEN TAKE A BITE
OF THIS WE'LL SEE THOSE THAT
TAKES A LOT CHEERS LOOK AT
THAT TO DEGREES. SO YEAH, IT'S
JUST CHEERS GOT CLOSE TO CARRY
ON
>> LOOK AT THAT. I DON'T TH